[Musique]
alors qu'emmanuel mal qu'on vit ces
derniers jours une rentrée plutôt elle
dit et
ce n'était apparemment pas près de
s'arranger le magazine public à paraître
demain contiendraient des informations
sur la vie privée du couple présidentiel
qui pourrait bien faire beaucoup parler
si ce n'est pas la première fois que des
rumeurs sur la vie personnelle des
manuels mâcon sont annoncés certains
s'insurgent que l'on puisse dévoiler des
détails intimes en une d'un magazine
people sur le couple présidentiel
et vous qu'en pensez-vous le magazine
public est il allé trop loin avec sa une
sur le président laüt au président et
brigitte on va la voir dans un instant
on aura bien sûr des infos grâce à
bernard montiel qui dort là bas
l'important est bien l'avion
fonctionnaires si myriam
myriam on va rappeler que vous êtes
directrice déléguée depuis que c'est à
dire peut-être directrice si vous êtes
elle également délégué de classe de
public c'est important de le dire avant
qu'on la boive directrice de rédaction
de public exact j'aurais été directrice
de tout pour moi au moins tu es
directrice de tout un voile à cette une
on va avoir un instant gill avant qu'on
la voit vous avez quoi dire à myriam
meriem palun pas jusque là je vous
appréciez et méritoire 6e toi même c'est
vraiment une âme je n'ais rien palombes
à bravo
non franchement je suis scandalisé là
vous dépasser tout ce que j'ai jamais vu
c'est à dire que le délit d' offense du
pigeon de la république n'existe plus
mais rien que pour vous j'aimerais
qu'ils vous attaquez book soyez condamné
vous prétendez dévoilé la vie sexuelle
du couple présidentiel en matant mal à
boire oui voilà voie avec une avec le
dogme qui me choque un article qui est
très à charge ou y a rien dedans vous
n'avez aucun respect et il m'a très bien
le gars lui s'il n'y a rien du tout il
est très zen en avoir écouté écoutez moi
c'est des accusations de 30p du fbi a
rassemblé à prendre la fuite d'autre
part ce qui m'énerve c'est que vous
confondez vos convictions personnelles
anti macron avec c'est vrai ça ça me
choque terrible votez pas d'accord à
souleymane dit n'importe quoi moi ces
tunnels me choque pas du tout et j'en ai
marre comptable sur la presse people
parce qu'elle est considérée comme une
sous presse mois sans dire ce qu'il ya
dedans j'ai lu l'article il n'y a rien
de choquant il recueille des infos qui
sont dans des médias de bobos comme
rolling stone magazine ou comme des
infos qui ont été reprises notamment des
prétendus liés on va en parler tout à
l'heure qui ont été relayés par france
inter quand ces médias en parlent
personne ne dit rien hélas quand ces
publics ils se font défoncer et c'est
complètement injuste au contraire bravo
à public de faire des dossiers qui
intéressent les gens on sait que c'est
pas facile pour la présence au monde
bravo à eux de continuer à voir des
lecteurs grâce à des dossiers comme ça
on va vous montrer la n 1 dans un
instant bien entendu vous mathieu
normaux vous êtes choqués mais je suis
très choqué mais je suis choquée comme
j'ai été choqué il n'y a pas très
longtemps de voir qu'un chanteur a
insulté le président de la république et
de voir que ce que vous faites là
également c'est insulter prenant
république on devrait aujourd'hui mais
véritablement tout comme on insulte un
flic aujourd'hui on est condamné on
devrait être condamnée à chaque fois
qu'on a qu'on insulte ou qu'on dit des
bêtises sur un président parce que c'est
pas sûr macron c'est sur la fonction
c'est la fonction qu'on insulte mais
pourquoi faire c'est une reine mais
qu'est ce que t'en sais ma chérie tu es
dans leur chambre tu as complètement
carré en ce moment il ya eu une insulte
bon enfin coûte qu'est ce que t'es en
train d' insulte à la connaissent pas
c'est ça pour le move activement c'est
pas une machine à mode pour être part
dans mon coeur je vous aime bien c'est
pas une machine à buzz pour essayer de
vendre y'a rien à l'article y'a rien
visiblement leur vie on va devoir vous
arrive tous or ça ne fait pas de pub
avec un torchon alors c'était un
magazine people
dommage ne transforme pas en ont mais ça
parce que c'est pas tenté pmt people
dont était fait pour des dix pmt people
du mouridisme c'est magnifique
de pouvoir la regarder voilà une idée
vous pas là alors voilà leur vie
sexuelle sous les projecteurs emmanuelle
et brigitte macro et en a plus qui
choque c'est leur vie sexuelle
alors vous vous êtes qui bernard montiel
vous qui les connaissaient mais est-ce
que vous êtes choqués
ben c'est à dire que oui quand on voit
ça comme ça on se dit tiens qu'est ce
qu'elle peut raconter parce que c'est
mais on parle de la lune laisse pas la
peine de balle elle est nulle part parce
que c'est là une que vous allez voir
je la trouve nu
contestable est fausse et ça veut rien
dire parce quand on connaît leur vraie
vie
vraie leur vie leur vie sexuelle qu'est
ce que vous en savez de laurier sexuelle
vous étiez vous avez appris sur ce que
j'ai dit est vrai nous avons reprises on
va être très clair nous avons repris les
informations d'une c4 combat ce sont des
rumeurs que vous avez en ont des
informations de mes informations s'il
vous plaît vous n'allez pas m'apprendre
mon métier d'artiste
déjà nous avons repris donc les
informations du très sérieux magazine
rolling stone en linkstone nous avons
donc repris qui d'ailleurs lui même
titre sur la vie sexuelle rêver de deux
des manuels macro supposé et non ils
disent pas supposé dans le titre de
l'article mais bon bien des jours
caroline qui le fait
voilà et si ce n'est pas bien donc déjà
rolling stones au public est ce qu a pas
une forme de respect à avoir envers le
président obama je vais bien content dit
ça mais ça n'a dérangé personne hollande
gayet
mais hollande était pas vraiment
président bah oui mais les échos
c'est marrant ça n'a rien à voir par
exemple la rupture cécilia sarkozy le
jamais dit non mais myriam c'est vrai
qu'on n'a jamais dit la vie sexuelle
d'un président c'est parce que guillaume
bienvenu une info en fait on n'est même
pas dans le people on est dans la
politique si c'était mon homme qui
détiendrait des informations
sexuels sur deux exils absolument le
titre tell break leur vie sexuelle est
sous les projecteurs on en parle même
aux états unis donc on est dans la
foulée ça me fait marrer voir tous les
suceurs du gouvernement qui se bouchent
le nez alors que ces mêmes sujets on les
a abordées battu la meilleure du monde
parle de qui de tout ce qui est quand on
en a parlé sur ce plateau de la
prétendue liaison de la rumeur de
liaison homosexuelle et mathieu gallet
avec mathieu guénand plateau je vous
entendez pas vous boucher pas le nez
donc arrêter
avec le principal intéressé est aisé de
l'arrêter mais il était un président
macro allait
effectivement ce que je te disais myriam
c'est que je pense qu'il ya vraiment une
différence entre la une qui a été fait
sur par exemple françois hollande où là
il s'agit d'une info que vous avez
vérifié le bon après qu'il ait mis les
viennoiseries il il est il est en photo
ils recevront chez julie gayet et là
c'est un fait politique majeur parce
qu'il a une autre femme qui est à
l'elysée et là on est là vous faites une
une sur entre pour l'instant juste du
vent s'il s'agit pour l'instant de
documents dont personne n'a eu la
possession que personne n'a lu qui sont
des soupes des documents supposer que le
net via n'y aurait que donald trump
auraient non non
son déchet
il fait ça semble qu'avec ces bons
chiffres sont tombés les
sacs adele rolling stones à ils ont eu
des proches et caetera et nous aussi on
a des infos ne comptez pas sur moi pour
pour pour dire quoi que ce soit ce soir
en plateau mais mais ça c'est trop
facile ben là c'est pire c'est du
plaisir alors on dit mais je n'ai pas
non plus envie de dire tout ce qu'il ya
dans le temps dans le dans le magazine
oui bah c'est vous qui me dit c'est bien
là les gars m'en voulais pas que les
gens l'achètent pour savoir maintenant
je vous ai de la vie d'annie donc il ya
un personnel dans que des rumeurs déjà
je vous expliquer quelque chose il ya
vraiment rien de personnel dans tout ça
dans la mesure même si c'est pas la
première s'il vous plaît vous aime
laisser parler oui merci vous vous êtes
anti macron et mokhtar et anti macroule
je suis quand je suis anti mac ronces
émirien pas l'onda qui parle là je parle
en tant que directrice déléguée de
public et je parle au nom de de nombreux
magazines et jeu est lent peu et est
faite fait ce sujet là ce n'est pas moi
qu'il est proposé c'est pas moi c'est
une non j'suis pas dire ce qu'elle a sur
relancé deux pseudo c'est une
journaliste femininbio menant à la
révolution s'il te plaît donc c'est une
journaliste qui l'a proposé moi je les
trouvais super on en a tous discuter
ensemble effectivement on était un peu
en amont parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est pas
la une de public hein je veux dire bfm a
fait tout à tout âge là tu y as le midi
me via le point d'ailleurs qui vous
dites y'a pas d'informations dans dans
public le point vient de sortir un
papier une confirme certaines
informations que nous avons également
mis dans le papier ces lois les
informations l'enfant
n'a aucune sais quoi qui a là aucune à
jean baptisé que c'est rien et des
oreilles
lors d'une perquisition chez donald
trump biya y trouver un document qui n'a
pu s'appellerait info président en
france voilà d'aidé depuis longtemps
fait pas salle c'est ce que serré le me
demande moi vous ne l'avez jamais été
mon chef
allez donc y aurait dans ce document des
accusations sur l'homosexualité d'
emmanuel macron voilà n'importe quoi non
pas du tout cecilio rien concède aucune
info tout court mais voilà on ne dit
jamais non temps de survie famille et
même pas dans le papier dans les
documents du bureau cela fout la merde
du papier scep soldats du papier marleix
demandiez ce qui a fait trois lieux
touche tellement exclamé dans le public
et ya
aussi le fait que mathieu gallet face à
promo pour son livre éclat chaque fois
il reparle de cette histoire de cette
rumeur comme quoi il aurait une relation
où il aurait eu et nous a dit que c'est
une énorme connerie mais sourit à chaque
fois comme ils l'on part sur les
plateaux ou en promo et tout ça ça free
ça fragiliserait la première dame voilà
en gros les os et ça les impôts de
l'afp
non j'ai peur voilà il avait demandé aux
gens d'aller acheter le magazine c'est
pas du tout ça à la fois prince et la
promo vous êtes l'avons pas les
meilleurs mais j'ai pas envie non plus
la raison de
finir ce que j'ai c'est que c'est un
procès d'intention qui est d'ailleurs
plus politique que rédactionnel le tout
pour ma grosse non je m'en fous voilà
mais le truc c'est que cette une a été
donc décidé au sein d'un comité de
rédaction validé par tous les
journalistes mais rien et que nous tous
d'accord pour nous dire ça rentre dans
notre ligne éditoriale c'est un bon
sujet dans notre ligne éditoriale il n'y
a aucune raison que nous ne le traitions
pas et nous avons volé des papiers des
papiers des taux nettement sur nicolas
sarkozy
bien sûr hollande et gayet alors parce
que ces mêmes
faits que des dossiers que que lors de
la perquisition de donald trump il ya eu
des dossiers sur emmanuel mâcon centre
complet encore fait parce que d'abord on
est tous d'accord maintenant maintenant
personne ne sait ce qu'est dedans mais
oui on a des infos effectivement 30
secondes et un faux dur
oui à l'ordonnancé mejia
[Applaudissements]
les infos de donald duck
non mais la lune pose pas de problèmes
internes finie que quand même sur sûr
sur cette histoire effectivement on a
l'info comme quoi donna truax son gré
d'avoir des documents sur la vie
sexuelle de m'accrocher pour finir il a
fait notre travail en amont non on sert
en mars il est chez moi m'avait réunir
moi non mais je vais prochainement avait
fauché les enquêtes on a on a fait le
boulot
non mais on a fait ça c'est tout y'a un
truc qui n'a pas encore été dit et même
étudiera après parce que je voudrais
avant olibrius moi je comprends pas en
fait ce qui vous dérange qu'est-ce qui
vous insurgez à travers tout ça pour une
fois qu'on a des journalistes qui osent
justement parlé d'un petit peu tout même
si ça pourrait toucher le président de
la république parce que bien souvent y
avait à voir non pas 10 matchs et à
leurs noms ne manquent pas de respect
syrie notamment deux mois j'ai lu
l'article non mais ça sent le maintien a
pris au niveau d'un rien alors pour
l'instant j'ai rien appris mécénat
alors c'est pas loin de là tu m'as tu vu
je suis d'accord avec toi l'instant je
n'ai rien appris de plus tous nos chers
c'est que le magazine public ça va
remuer un petit peu les choses on va pas
se mentir ça fait quatre ans qu'on
entende parler toutes ces histoires
maintenant j'ai juste une seule chose à
dire ce soir si trump il a des éléments
s'il te plaît tout comme sa
victoire de l'eau de javel celle
de doute le preneur à l'eau deux fois
les appeler non
mais moi je suis content mais continue
continue d'énoncer la vérité
il y aurait des documents que les sites
qui pourraient attester de
l'homosexualité
même si les homosexuels
sincèrement ça me dérange pas mais
qu'ils l'assument nom de dieu
qu'on en a à [ __ ] on
devra l'assumer il faut l'assumer ces
écoutes c'est quand même le président
alors les français il se parait de quoi
que ce soit on en 2020 même si emmanuel
macron et l'homosexuel ariane
sur des rumeurs d'un document qui aurait
été trouvé
mais rien ne dit pas ça dans public bien
sûr et des passages à
jendouba
con ce qui est vrai c'est que
effectivement ces documents c'est très
pris au sérieux par l'elysée et que et
que effectivement ils sont très inquiet
et c'est pour ça qu'on a dit rien ne va
plus donc nous on a vraiment mais rien à
se reprocher on a exactement fait le
travail qu'il fallait qu'on fasse pour
public je suis désolé s'est dit vraiment
ce qui se passe ils sont inquiet que ces
documents sort c'est vrai et que du coup
c'est ce qu'on raconte enfin excusez moi
en compte celle à croke park
c'était booba rohff et sign
contre le fait qu'il ya une vraie
volonté de nuire dans le choix de la
photo mais on promit pas des sardines
oui ensuite tu oublies une volonté de
nuire public comme closer comme vassy à
une vraie nécessité de scoop c'est sa
marque de fabrique depuis le début on
cite ronson donc ce ne sont pas des
comme et scoop vous avez fait un résumé
de tout ce qui est payante et ailleurs
et puis ça non attention je ne pense que
le geipan de longue durée je pense que
vous ne savez pas lire donc j'en suis
désolé ou fait que vous avez une
mauvaise vue je ne sais pas mais ce
n'est pas du tout ce n'est pas du tout
ça nous ce qu'on explique c'est que y'a
dit je voudrais pas le seul secret le
seul secret donc voilà il y c'est que
voilà délit aussi dans le daily mail
voilà que des infos sérieuses et sucrés
trouver chez donald trump raconterez en
fait qu emmanuel macron a connu et tombe
amoureux de brigitte à saison et qu'ils
ont une relation très tôt contre l'avis
d'emmanuel aussi voilà le long mais sans
ce label n'est
pas des infos employeur oui non mais en
fait c'est ça certains parlent du non
respect de la fonction présidentielle
mais en fait le nerf de la guerre c'est
pas de parler de la vie sexuelle du
président le non-respect ce serait qu'un
président qu'on a élu pendant deux
quinquennats nous montrent sur ce qu'il
est et ce maintenant il est
bien sûr comme jamais
il peut pas utiliser une couverture
c'est à dire tu dis voilà je m'appelle
comme ça
[Musique]
rappelle alors
de quoi on parle a qu à quel sujet tu
dis ça le fait qu'il ait connu tous sur
le fait qu'ils auraient des rumeurs
comme quoi ils se moquent issue aurait
menti sur le fait qu'ils seraient par
exemple homosexuel et que pendant deux
quinquennats il nous présente sa femme
et sa vie de famille c'est à dire que
cette chanson je te comprends bien et
donc ça ce serait un mensonge s'aggrave
sa fille c'est
un fait je mets ces plantes pareils mais
le chercher sa fille étaient payés avec
l'argent des français en revanche un
président qui coût serait quasiment sa
vie sexuelle dans l'elysée n'avait rien
n'a bougé
je moi je dis pas du tout que les
manuels macro est homosexuel en bas de
ça que je dis mais si c'est le cas si
ces doubles six mêmes le disent je
le dis
m reviens moi c'est louis dowler motard
me la
suis sortie
physique machine et méprisante le en
levrette le monde
[Applaudissements]
sait
en tout cas bon jagla fait de mes bonnes
comme celle là ça va sauf que si c'est
vrai ou alors
je suis pas sûr que l'électorat lilas
aurait forcément voté pour lui dont des
toits du tout voiture alors qu'il
évacuait a expliqué non je me tais tu
m'as dit de céder vous parlez
incorrigiblement intelligiblement
la sexualité d'un président n'entre pas
dans les dents les deniers des français
ce qu'il fait là nuit bien sûr j'ai
d'accord avec un homme d'abord il fait
ce qu'il veut il n'a à le dire ça fait
pas pression dit que je finis un
président de dire qu'il est malade parce
que ça joue sur le pays doit directement
qu'il elle vit cachée parce qu'on la
paye mais ce qu'il fait là nuit qui
couche avec brigitte ou avec un homme a
bien sûr ça n'a besoin de rien il n'a
pas le dieu d'accord imagine entendre
que ça sera une accusation et que grave
je serai grave attentat disent par
exemple je suis un président célibataire
mais pas par exemple je suis dans marié
faut pas dire ça faut pas mentir ou
alors tu parles pas de passé militaire
et du bien merci sur quinze jours à
l'accord je suis d'accord avec moi tu
vois la région a dit noyer non moi je
suis pas vraiment d'accord avec mathieu
moi je pense qu'un président alors le
problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui il n'y a
plus de deux politiques sacré on
pourrait le regretter
on le regrette et oui mais c'est des
people comme les autres et finalement
quand macro et enfin le couple macron
demande admis marchand d'organiser la
une de paris match parce qu'à l'époque
ils sont pas people finalement il est
bien content de trouver la presse people
à ce moment là je pense que tout
non mais toujours été fait ça tous nos
frères reid en fait on fait des pauses
on fait des photos pour le fait des
coupes 2e d'un magazine risque là
explique pauline en baisse mais non mais
là dessus mais ça n'a rien à voir tout
le monde l'a fait il observer qu'ils ont
avait pas de vent nul n'y avait pas d
une sur chirac ou sur est venue sur un
an rené coty disait rené coty lui
manquer de respect non je trouve que
c'est moi je crois que je suis pour le
respect de la fonction présidentielle
quel qu'il soit que vous ayez voté pour
lens a aussi c'est hollande qui oui mais
pas vraiment président c'est ça oui mais
non pas du tout il était passé ça s'est
toujours abordé tendue se fier aux
médecins non mais moi dans les mêmes
même pour hollande moi je me suis
toujours demandé comment hollande a
laissé passer ça franchement c'est
toujours été d'un fait politique majeur
et c'était un terme et ça c'est une
politique je ne sais pas danser dossier
sassou c'est hyper important c'est à
souillac on n'en sait rien si la soul ya
des trucs nous raconte et je suis désolé
si ça peut permettre à ces dossiers s'il
existe vraiment de sortir je trouve que
voilà c'est notre lot 6 de le faire et
un il a une vision pour la france
matheron et ben il peut y avoir aussi
des visions personnelles quand les jets
adhésion est différente non mais non la
digital à gré des besoins de savoir ce
qui gouverne la france et puis aussi
intimement et personnellement
annie promouvoir le public qui fait
couler beaucoup d'encre s'il vous plaît
regardez voilà alors c'est vrai qu'elle
a fait énormément parler elle va faire
énormément parce qu'on pensait
téléspectateurs tiens est ce qu'elle
vous choque vous qui nous rejoignent et
oui à 46% nous voilà à
53% donc c'est vrai que voilà il ya ya
ya beaucoup de gens qui qui qui parle de
ça mais eux est-ce que vous allez avoir
des problèmes myriam avec cette union
penser
on verra on en juge alors il ya plus de
délits d' offense du présent mais il
peut attaquer en diffamation
excusez moi comme tout citoyen normal
n'ont jamais cessé d'aimer et
vous êtes meilleurs comment ça non
mais je sais très bien je sais très bien
que vous emmener au mot près fait
expertiser avec vos avoirs où il va donc
ils sont pas cons mais non
si désolée attaqué
magazine que tu détestes mais non
sans magazine
je voudrais simplement dire parce que
souvent vous me brancher par rapport à
eux je les connais bien juste assure je
peux vous dire que ce couple là
tellement fusionnel tellement amoureux
tellement merveilleux et c'est vrai et
oui eh ben je les envie c'est un couple
merveilleux très amoureux et je souhaite
qu'un jour il ya amoureux ça vous
calmera
[Applaudissements]
je vais être très clair avec vous
bernard ya rien de personnel quant à ma
vie amoureuse elle va très bien merci je
sais ça fait 23 sens-tu avec le même
mais tout va bien je suis content qu'on
ne voit pas
certainement parce que je ne sais quoi
c'est pas ça servait les vrais visages
et j'en suis ravi c'est vrai que de ce
que je sais où aussi paraît que ça se
passe très bien mais évidemment de ce
que des uns vis des amis de jeu libre la
série des petites envies de vie alors
j'y viens gilles est ce que est ce que
tu as une info est ce qu'ils ont essayé
de parce que la une a été d'être bloqués
non ils sont inquiets mais ils peuvent
pas essayé de bloquer ses pires parce
qu'après ça sort donc ils n'ont pas
essayé de bloquer mais c'est vrai qu'à
une inquiétude ils se sont jetés sur
l'heure à gaz il semble que non mais il
ya une inquiétude c'est vrai absolument
non pas que je t'ai surtout les
magazines vont pas toutes les lâchetés
annonce a toutefois vous rigolez à
l'elysée sari alesi allégations à
l'essai ont bien sûr moi ça me rappelle
une histoire moi il ya très longtemps
ya très longtemps je vous jure que c'est
vrai je suis je suis avec eux j'étais
avec eux quelqu'un l'a longtemps je
pensais être connu et si non mais c'est
vrai que c'est vrai c'est vrai ce site à
l'époque de m6 et m6 et donc je suis
avec quelqu'un et je me fais choper avec
une bâche l'oreille tu as non ouais et
je sors je suis en week end avec mon
officiel et je sors d'abord je dis tiens
mais je vais chercher le maillot je sors
et je vois le ce kiosque avec en une ma
gueule les bachelorette c'est comme les
cacahuètes
voix main dans la main avec une
majorette et là j'ai vu je vais voir le
gall et il rassure toute la plage
c'était sur la can je dis je vais voir
tous les gages d enlever sans enlever ça
comme je fredonne jourdain a même enlevé
moi ça au moins qu'on le voit pas contre
la passe et s'est donné un billet à tous
les gars pour qu'ils enlèvent juste le
bail en bois après mais la vue forcément
mais voilà c'est vrai ça va arriver
ça donne envie de retrouver 7e une
exception voici mes vrais je me rappelle
est c'était ça c'est pour vous dire ça
fait ça fait mal donc peut-être qu'ils
vont tout racheter voilà c'est public
mais rien parce que vous en voici le
journal o à l'elysée ou pas mais il le
sera pas non plus pourquoi tout est une
question non plus par l'accord du
journaliste enfin je sais pas je vais
pourquoi je reviens à l'elysée ses
services
il ya le patron de la commune m6 qui me
dit tu vois je te faisais une bonne
comme à l'époque
now brasparts non mais voilà bon écoutez
en tout cas ça fait énormément parler
cette affaire